Lannister's don't act like fools you gonna say
something clever go on say something clever
when you hear them whispering Kingslayer
behind your back doesn't it bother you of
course it bothers me the lion doesn't concern
himself with the opinions of a sheep I need
you to become the man you were always meant
to be not next year not tomorrow it is said
that the men of the mountain clans are great
warriors ride with me against my enemies and
you shall have all my son promised you and
more only if the half man fights with us
we must return to Casterly Rock to raise huh
my son get out all of you or I'll carve your
lungs out boy you do no such thing this one's a
girl you idiot we've worked through the night my
lord perhaps we'd profit from some sleep yes I
think you would Reginald and because you're my
cousin I might even let you wake from that sleep
can you read the cupbearer can read better than
you to whom does house dormand owe allegiance my
lord to the Starks of Winterfell who have 20,000
men and my son I judged you might be good for
something more than brutalizing peasants where
is your father is he alive what killed him
loyalty you're a sharp little thing aren't
you killing them isn't the problem it's finding
them you gone soft Clegane I always thought you
had a talent for violence let them know what
it means to choose the wrong side you hungry
no course you are eat I'll eat in the kitchen
theta it's bad manners to refuse a Lords offer
the battle is over we have one
the savior of the city and the hand of the king
little bloody gratitude would this start jugglers
and singers require applause you are a Lannister
and I would let myself be consumed by maggots
before mocking the family name and making you heir
to Casterly Rock why why I'm not sir in this man's
whole career you are an ill-made spiteful little
creature and to teach me humility that gods have
condemned me to watch you waddle about wearing
that proud lion that was my father's sigil and
his father's before him but neither God's nor men
will ever compel me to let you turn Casterly Rock
into your whorehouse audrey has her claws in
Joffrey she knows how to manipulate him good
I wish you knew how to manipulate him he'll marry
ser Loras No I won't do it that you will are still
fertile you need to marry again and breed I am
Queen Regent not some broodmare my daughter you
will do as I command and you will marry Loras
Tyrell if you refuse to marry Loras to Cersei
I will name him to the Kingsguard he will never
marry he will never have children the Tyrell name
will fade so shall i door up the order it's a rare
enough thing a man who lives up to his reputation
so if I wanted to attend a council meeting I would
now have to climb all the stairs in the Tower of
the hand we could arrange to have you carried
drink you can joke you can engage in juvenile
attempts to make your father uncomfortable but
you will do your duty I am the king any man who
must say I am the king is no true king my father
won the real war he killed Prince Rhaegar he took
the crown while you hid on a costly rock the king
is tired see him to his chambers to celebrate go
if serving as a glorified bodyguard is the sum of
your ambition go serve the mountain follows your
orders of course I blame you men at war commit
all kinds of crimes without their superiors
knowledge he denied involvement in Elias murder
categorically I demand a trial by combat [Music]
you want it to be dead yes but you
refuse to die I respect that you
can admire it you fight for what's
yours I'd never let them execute you
is that what you fear I'll never let you
in pain take your head you're a Lannister